delicia fernando her husband anton and
their three children were attending
easter sunday mass at san antonio's
church when a suicide bomber struck
now
there was a loud noise and fire started
raining down from the roof i told my
girls to head out my son was thrown by
the impact he's the one who found my
husband dead
a total of seven suicide bombers struck
three churches and three hotels all
within an hour
two hundred and seventy people were
killed and more than five hundred
injured
the government blamed an obscure local
group the national tawhid jamaat
but many people don't accept that
explanation
opposition mp harin fernando is one of
them biggest question for me is
who benefited out of this and why can't
the government when we raise questions
answer
fernando says vital information
uncovered by both the parliamentary
committee and presidential commission
has not been investigated
the catholic church has been scathing
about the investigation
cardinal malcolm ranjit the archbishop
of colombo has frequently criticized the
slow pace of the investigation
and implied that people now in
government may have been involved in the
attacks
government representatives and the
police deny those allegations
they point out that hundreds of suspects
have been detained and indictments
issued in a dozen cases
lawyers for some of them have told al
jazeera that their clients had no
involvement with the bombing
meanwhile delicia and dozens like her
face a long wait for justice
i've told god only you can show me the
way to secure justice because people
keep exchanging allegations about who
did it while the years go by we can't
live with peace of mind
they can only hope their prayers are
answered
nell fernandez joins us live from sri
lanka's capital colombo minell what
happened in court today
basically if we with the 25 men
appearing before this special court in
fact
the proceedings have come to an end for
the day and you might just catch a
glimpse of some of the suspects over my
shoulder uh you can just see their backs
they have finished their case they're
just waiting for transport to be taken
to the different ribbon prisons that
they've been brought from now we had
some of the lawyers making appeals to
court uh some of them said that they
wanted to make bail applications because
obviously this is going to be a long
trial 23 000 charges they said they
wanted to submit applications for bail
however they were told by judges that
bail applications by a number of those
who wish to make them would be taken up
at the next hearing which has been fixed
for the third of march but there were
other things like there was one lawyer
who brought to the notice of the court
that four men claiming to be local
police from his clients area had gone
into his client's house spoken to his
mother who was alone at the house at the
time demanded to know who uh the council
or lawyer that was representing her son
was and how much he was being paid he
said this was out of order and shouldn't
have been done there are other
sort of requests that had been made of
the court for some of the prisoners to
be given qurans some of them had had
the quran to read while in riman prison
but
you know when they had been transferred
around this hadn't been taken
as well as a final thing the
translations of those indictments still
not ready in the tamil language which a
majority of these suspects speak and the
government lawyers said by the next
hearing they would uh probably be pretty
sure that these charges would be made
available so they understand what
they're being charged with
now the catholic church has been highly
critical of this entire investigation
why is that
they have seen sort of rising
frustrations with the way this has
progressed they say that the government
the investigators
have not uh sort of investigated all
lines of uh sort of inquiry that obvious
things
obvious connections clues have not been
pursued and they have actually raised
questions as to why this is there is a
presidential commission of inquiry that
was appointed that basically handed over
something like 22 volumes of uh
proceedings it's only the very first
that has been formally sort of presented
into the public and everyone says that
if you go through those there's a
lot of evidence that has been presented
that raise a lot of questions which
haven't been inquired into which is what
we see the 25 men some of whom you again
see behind me uh these are just some of
the people that have been accused with
aiding and abetting and the church says
there are very high profile figures uh
there is even sort of allegations that
military intelligence knew of the
mastermind and had indeed he'd been on
their payroll as an informant of course
the government has denied it so these
are reasons that the catholic church is
very very critical and said that more
must be done to ensure that justice is
served
okay thank you for that update minelle
fernandez therefore in colombo